- Like if we're talkin'
flavor town, this one is like
it knocks you right the
(beep) out in the face.
(swooshing)
(creaking)
(popping)
(upbeat music)
- When people think of curry,
they think of curry in like Asia.
- My knowledge of curry only expands
from Trinidadian dishes.
- People try to make it
like an Indian thing.
- Outside of the east Asian community,
I don't know how common it is for
people to consume or know
about Japanese curry.
- So today, we will be trying different
types of curry from around the world.
(whooshing)
(upbeat music)
(pops)
(whooshes)
- [Woman] Hmm.
- Hmm. Mm.
- So like in Idian dishes, or at least
in my family, I don't want to speak
for everyone, we don't really
say this type of curry.
We'll say, Tikka Masala,
or this type of dish.
- So it's definitely
different from Japanese curry.
- Slightly spicy, it's slightly sweet.
- And the color is such a brilliant color.
- Whenever my family
makes Caribbean dishes,
the curry is like a deeper color.
Like a deeper brown.
- I've had curries like this before,
but this isn't like necessarily
what my family would make.
We don't really make mango based curries.
- India's so diverse. Yeah.
- [Woman] It's good.
- It's really good.
(upbeat music)
(pops)
(whooshes)
- This is what I'm talkin' about when
I said that curry was darker.
- Looks like something my
mom would make at home.
- Look at the stainage.
- Oh wow. Yeah.
- Yep.
- That is so tender. Sorry.
Just talkin' with my mouth open.
- It's a lot heartier.
It almost feels like a stew.
- Mm hmm.
- It's also drier which
I think is interesting.
- The juices are like almost
like the sauce part of it.
- This is actually like really good.
- Definitely expanded my mind on what
curry is and it is delicious (laughs).
- I would eat it again.
(whooshes)
(upbeat music)
(pops)
(whooshes)
- So this is the kind of
curry that I ate growing up.
- It's like sweet and tangy.
- It smells really good.
- Usually it has like a lot of
potatoes and carrots and meat and stuff.
- I like the consistency of it.
- It's really good.
- It's not from somewhere unseemless.
- Right?
- Where you can just
normally have access to.
- This is definitely. This is it.
- I totally understand that it is
nearly impossible to describe
curry as a type of food.
- It definitely expanded
my mind out of Asia.
- Curry, defining it and
understanding it is really complex.
- We're limited by the language we have.
Whereas these authentic dishes
have different words for them
in their own regions with
a larger breadth than just what
the word curry to us can contain.
- [Woman] Bone.
(laughing)
(whooshing)
(creaking)